since the colonization of the americas a
huge number of indigenous languages have
disappeared and of the remaining ones
most are endangered but one language
that has been remarkably resilient is
guarani also known by its endonym
gualani is not just an official language
of paraguay alongside spanish but it's
also spoken by the majority of the
population there including a large
number of non-indigenous people
varieties of guarani are spoken by
smaller communities in the neighboring
countries of bolivia argentina and
brazil guarani is a member of the tupi
guarani branch of the toupeen language
family it's more precisely a group of
closely related languages some of which
form a dialect continuum with each other
but some varieties have low mutual
intelligibility the most widely spoken
variety is paraguayan guarani which has
an estimated six to seven million
speakers
proto-topian the language from which all
topian languages developed is thought to
have been spoken in the madeira river
basin in the brazilian region of
chondonia near the bolivian border
migrations from this region brought
dupian to various parts of south america
where it began to diverge into different
languages including guarani not much is
known about guarani before spanish and
portuguese colonists began to arrive in
the 16th century because it was not a
written language the first people to
document and describe it were jesuit
missionaries
spanish colonists established the city
of asuncion in the year 1537 but because
of its isolated location and lack of
natural resources few spanish people
migrated there after it was initially
established the spanish settlers were
almost all men who married indigenous
guarani women their children who became
the elites in the following generations
were bilingual in guarani and spanish
which secured a place for guarani in
paraguayan society if the spanish had
set up a full administration there and a
bigger spanish population had been
brought over the spanish language would
have likely dominated and guarani would
be limited to a rural indigenous
minority as happened with indigenous
languages elsewhere in latin america the
fact that they didn't see asuncion as
very important and neglected it probably
helped guarani to survive as a majority
language
jesuit missionaries also helped the
language survive they built jesuit
missions known as reductions a type of
settlement for indigenous guarani people
that operated autonomously from spanish
colonialist rule of course their goal
was colonialist in the sense that they
wanted to convert guarani people to
catholicism and european way of life but
they used the guarani language in their
efforts and they developed a system of
writing the language they also created a
standardized form of the language and
compiled guarani dictionaries grammars
and textbooks later when spain forced
the jesuit missionaries to leave
monolingual guarani speakers from the
missions migrated throughout the country
including to the cities
after paraguay gained its independence
from spain in 1811 the country's first
dictator used guarani as a nationalist
rallying cry and he also prohibited the
small number of spanish colonials from
marrying each other which essentially
resulted in forced race mixing and more
bilingualism
subsequent governments not only reversed
that coercive policy but they also
repressed the guarani language and
banned it in schools though governments
used guarani to inspire nationalistic
pride in times of war of course how
convenient
by the middle of the 20th century
populist politicians began speaking of
guarani more favorably to appeal to the
guarani speaking majority in 1967 it was
made a national language though spanish
remained the only official language and
in 1992 guarani was made an official
language alongside spanish
according to the 2012 census results
46.3 percent of households used both
guarani and spanish and 34 percent used
only guarani that means over 80 percent
of paraguayans speak guarani
the majority of guarani speakers use a
form of the language called
that involves heavy code switching with
spanish the word yopara means mixture
unlike the simple integration of spanish
loanwords referred to as
refers to actual code switching or code
mixing that includes elements of spanish
grammar the form of guarani used in
schools is not yo para but a more
traditional and literary form of the
language
let's take a look at some of the
features of guarani the orthography of
guarani is based on the latin
orthography used for spanish with a few
extra characters that represent guadalee
sounds that don't appear in spanish
all syllables consist of a vowel or a
consonant plus a vowel no syllables end
in consonants at least for native
guarani words for example mighty meaning
hello
meaning how are you and this is often
used as a greeting instead of maite
meaning fine or good
and you ipo
i'm fine too
guarani has six pairs of vowels six oral
vowels plus their nasal equivalents
all voiced stops and the one affricate
are pre-nasalized they only occur before
oral vowels their allophones are the
nasal consonants which occur before
nasal vowels replacing an oral consonant
with a nasal consonant to match adjacent
nasal sounds is an important feature of
guarani guarani has nasal harmony if
there's a stressed nasal vowel or a
nasal consonant its nasality spreads to
adjacent parts of the word this happens
with certain prefixes for example one
such prefix is the first person plural
inclusive subject pronoun prefix ja
which comes before an oral verb stem
before a nasal verb stem it becomes
so there's
meaning we laugh or we laughed and
there's
meaning we speak or we spoke so as a
little side note here guarani has a
distinction between we which includes
the listener and we which excludes the
listener
guarani is agglutinative meaning that
rather than adding additional words to a
sentence to show grammatical
distinctions multiple prefixes and
suffixes can be added instead here's an
example this phrase means see you later
the root is this verb
meaning c the subject is prefixed before
the verb root
we see then another prefix is added
between the subject prefix and verb root
to show reciprocation
we see each other then an adverb meaning
until is added after the verb
until we see each other or just see you
later
also nouns they take suffixes to show
number and case but not gender
this means cat
and this means cats
is an optional plural marker when it
comes after a nasal vowel it becomes
this means child
and this means children
the child loves the cat notice
at the end of the word for cat this is a
suffix that indicates the accusative
case for animate objects and it can also
show the locative case like for a
destination or location some other such
suffixes are we which indicates the
ablative case like from and
or
as a separate word which indicates
accompaniment like with
syntax notice the word order of this
sentence s-v-o this is the most common
word order in basic declarative
sentences but in reality the word order
is flexible and it's fairly common for
the subject to come after the verb and
for objects to come before the verb
notice that there's no definite article
no word meaning the there's no native
definite article in guadagni but the
spanish definite articles la and lo are
often used in daily conversation though
this would be considered yo para
possession what if we want to say the
child loves his cat or her cat
e is a prefix that functions as a
possessive adjective this one being
third person the other possessive
adjectives are separate words that
aren't prefixed like this
they're data this means your name a data
means name specifically a given name not
a family name
what's your name
my name is wan
when the possessor is an actual noun it
still comes before the thing that is
possessed
means my father's name
means my father and you already know
that veda means name
this means my father's name is jose
verbs guarani verbs feature something
called split intransitivity or an active
state of split transitive verbs are
active while intransitive verbs can be
either active or stative the active
verbs use active subject prefixes which
there are two different classes of while
the state of verbs use inactive subject
pronoun prefixes they're the same as the
possessives that we saw earlier and the
same as the standalone subject pronouns
except for the third person for example
i walk or i walked this is active
i remember or i remembered this is
stative notice that in addition to the
subject pronoun prefix that's attached
to the verb a standalone subject pronoun
is optionally used
but normally only to emphasize or
clarify stative verbs in guarani are
generally used for states or things that
happen that the person involved has no
control over and active verbs are
generally used for intentional actions
under the control of the subject but in
practice there are plenty of exceptions
so you really need to memorize which
verbs are active versus stative
grammatically speaking there's really no
distinction between state of verbs and
adjectives or nouns which can be used as
a predicate by adding an inactive
subject pronoun here's an example
i'm angry literally i anger here's
another example
i have a dog literally i dog this could
also be expressed with an independent
verb
in this case the verb is an active
transitive verb
tense and aspect in guarani when verbs
don't have any specific tense marking
they can be interpreted as either
present tense or past tense depending on
the context but there are also tense and
aspect markers that can come after the
verb for the distant past theirs
this means he lived in paraguay at some
point in the past
for the future tense there's the suffix
tayata
is actually a loanword from spanish
which is incorporated into a guadagni
grammatical structure this kind of
assimilation of spanish loanwords is
called
the native guadagni word for study is
i'm going to study tomorrow to make a
negative future statement
is replaced by
i'm not going to study tomorrow negation
itself is indicated by a circumfix a
combination of a prefix and a suffix
that surround the verb
plus
there's also a postposition that shows
progressive aspect
or after a nasal verb stem
this means i'm studying now
in literary guarani
is actually a conjugated suffix that's
different depending on person and number
but in everyday speech it's widely used
as a standalone aspect marker
there are also prefixes that can be
added to verbs to indicate mood like
subjunctive and imperative and there are
other derivations like causation and
desire which are suffixed and reflexive
and reciprocal which are prefixed take
this imperative sentence
this means please show me word for word
it's imperative prefix for active verbs
c
causative requested of imperative suffix
first person singular indirect object
pronoun in other words me the imperative
here involves an imperative prefix e
while na is an extra suffix that softens
a command or makes it more polite this
is called the requestative or the
rogative
is a causative suffix so if you add it
to the verb
which means to see then it means to show
like to make someone see
a moment ago we saw that verbs can have
a suffix that indicates past or future
in guarani nouns can too
for past tense either
are used and for future tense
is used for example
means wife
means future wife or fiance when
referring to a woman
means ex-wife
sometimes both suffixes can be added
that may sound strange like how can it
be both past and future but think about
this example
this means former fiancee when referring
to a woman
notice that the suffix que becomes
because the preceding vowel is nasal
another interesting feature of guarani
is its demonstratives words like this
these that and those in english there
are only two distinctions near and far
in guarani demonstratives have several
distinctions near
unmarked or middle distance far distance
absent or previously mentioned unseen
but audible or previously mentioned
this picture is beautiful this is the
demonstrative expressing that the
picture is near the speaker then there's
the word for picture
then we have the adjective
which is made predicative by adding an
inactive subject pronoun in this case
the third person
that picture is beautiful referring to a
picture that is not present when the
people are talking about it
earlier in the video i spoke briefly
about yo para but let's take another
look at it the degree to which people
mix guarani and spanish depends on the
person and the situation and it can
range from mostly guarani with some
spanish elements to mostly spanish with
some guarani elements older people and
people in the countryside tend to use
more traditional guarani and lestio para
while younger people and people in the
cities tend to use more job
here's an example of what yopara might
look like
this means i don't have that much
knowledge word for word it's i negative
i have negative that much knowledge
notice that the last two words are from
spanish
in traditional guarani this might be
which translates to i don't have so much
knowledge in this sentence all the words
are of guarani origin
or a more natural way of saying it might
be
which means i don't know so much
word for word it's i negative i know
negative so much
it's worth noting that many speakers and
proponents of more traditional guarani
have a distaste for job
and see it as a degraded form of the
language but the majority of speakers
speak some form of yobara
hopefully this video has given you an
interesting glimpse at the guarani
language unfortunately it's not an easy
language to find learners resources for
duolingo has a guadagni course for
spanish speakers but it's quite
underdeveloped i've found some other
simple courses on memrise but they're
very basic i do have one good book about
guarani but it's a grammar of the
language rather than a textbook for
learners if you know of any other
resources for learners feel free to
write them in the comments down below
and that brings me to the question of
the day for speakers of guarani
particularly in paraguay to what extent
do you mix guarani in spanish do you use
one more than the other does it depend
on the situation and to other people
what's your impression of guarani leave
your comments down below and now i'd
like to say thanks to all the lang
focused patreon supporters who make it
much easier to keep this channel going
month after month i want to especially
thank the ones whose names appear on the
screen because they are the top tier
patreon supporters many extra special
thanks go out to them and everyone thank
you for watching and have a nice day
[Music]
you